[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمو
حول العالم احداث تتفاعل وتتصاعد
هذه الصور من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس التي
تشهد احتجاجات
وهذه الاحتجاجات تشهد تصاعدا كبيرا بعد
قرار الرئيس الفرنسي مكروه اقرار مشروع
قانون اصلاح التقاعد متجاوزا البرلمان
لعدم قدرته على تامين الاغلبيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في اقتحام هو العاشر لجنين منذ بدء العام
قوه الاحتلال تغتال قياديين في سرايا
القدس وكتائب القسام في جنين ضمن عمليه
تصفيه شملت اربعه فلسطينيين وبعد توعد
الفصائل بالرد اسرائيل تعلن رفع حاله
التاهب استعدادا لاحتمال اطلاق صواريخ من
قطاع غزه
تقول ان ظروف التصعيد قائمه وتحذر من
اتساع الصراع
في تداعيات تحطم المسيره الامريكيه فوق
البحر الاسود بعد يومين على الحادثه
واشنطن تكشف عن صوره اعتراض المقاتلات
الروسيه للمسيره واتهامات للكريند باتخاذ
القرار ومع تلويح وزير الدفاع الروسي
بالرد على اي طلعات جويه امريكيه قباله
القرم البيت الابيض يقول ان استخدام
المسيرات فوق البحر الاسود سيستمر
تقارير عن الاستعداد لبدء تعبئه رابعه لسد
النهضه تجدد السجان المصري الاثيوبي اديس
ابابا تقول انها ملتزمه بتسويه تحفظ مصالح
الجميع وترفض تلويح السلطات المصريه
بخيارات مفتوحه
والقاهره تقول ان المفاوضات تشهد جمودا
وتشدد على ان قضيه السد اولويه وجوديه
على وقع التوتر المتصاعد في شرق اسيا لاول
مره منذ 12 عاما اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه
يعقدان قمه في طوكيو ساعيا لطي صفحه
الخلافات
وكوريا الشماليه تطلق صاروخا عابرا
للقارات تعهد امريكي بالدفاع عن الحلفاء
في وجه تهديدات
والصين تتهم اليابان بزعزعه السلم وتقول
ان توجهها للعسكره امر خطير
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا قرار بريطانيا حظر استخدام
تيك توك على جميع الهواتف الحكوميه بتهمه
تشكيله خطرا على البيانات الحساسه الى
جانب حديث في الولايات المتحده نقله
عن طلب وجهها للملاك الصينيين للاسهم ببيع
حصصهم في شركه تيك توك او حظر في الولايات
المتحده ما لم يفعلوا ذلك ترد بيجين بان
واشنطن لم تقدم دليلا حتى الان على تهديد
المنصه لامنها لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
كيف ستؤثر الاجراءات الغربيه الجاريه
والمحتمله على منصه تيك توك 18 راوا انها
ستؤدي لتراجع حضور المنصه
بينما قال
21% ان المنصه ستخضع للمطالب اما واحد
وستون في المئه فاعتبروا هذه الاجراءات
غير مؤثره
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
تيك توك بين الاتهامات والدوافع ستكون
حاضره بتفاصيل اكثر في الحصاد
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
فرنسا مشهد المواجهات والاحتجاجات نحو
التصعيد بعد قرار رئاسي يتجاوز عتبه
البرلمان لاقرار قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
مشهد متصاعد في الضفه الغربيه بعد تنفيذ
قوات الاحتلال عاشر اقتحام لها لمدينه
جنين منذ بدايه العام فقط الهدف كان قتل
قائدين عسكريين في سرايا القدس وكتائب
القسام وقد تم الامر على يد وحده
اسرائيليه خاصه لم تكن هذه الحصيله فقط
فقد قتل فلسطينيين اخرين بينهما طفل فيما
جرح ثلاثه وعشرون شخصا بعد الاقتحام توعدت
فصائل فلسطينيه بالرد وهو ما قالت قوه
الاحتلال انها تتاهب له الان تحسبا لاطلاق
محتمل لصواريخ من قطاع غزه تتهم السلطه
الفلسطينيه حكومه الاحتلال بمحاوله تفجير
الاوضاع فيما تعلق القياده الامريكيه
الوسطى بان الظروف مهيئه للتصعيد
ولا يعلم من اي باب او شراره
سيتسع التصيد
في وضح النهار وحده من قوه المستعربين
العسكريه الاسرائيليه دخلت الى اكثر
الشوارع حيويه وسط مدينه جنين
الهدف اغتيال القائدين في كتيبه جنين نضال
خازن من سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي ويوسف الشريم القيادي في
كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس
كان معا على دراجه هوائيه جنود وحده
المستعربين باغتوهما واطلقوا وابل من
الرصاص عليهما
اكتشف الاهالي امرهم
وحاولوا محاصره سياره المستعربين الذين
اطلقوا النار على كل من هاجمهم الى ان
تدخلت وحدات من جيش الاحتلال اخراج
السياره عقب ذلك اشتباكات مسلحه بين
مقاومين وقوات الاحتلال انتهت باستشهاد
فتى ورجل فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر من 23
اخرين
الاهالي يتقدمهم عشرات المقاومين المسلحين
من اذرع المقاومه كافه صاروا في مدينه
جنين يحملون نعش الشهداء الاربعه ويرددون
شعارات تطالب بالانتقام ومواصله المقاومه
وعلى المستوى الابدي والسياسي الفلسطيني
تزداد نبره الغضب حده ما كان لهذا الذي
يجري من جرائم ان يستمر لولا المعايير
المزدوجه التي تمارسها الاسره الدوليه
وشعور الجنان قتله بالافلات من العقاب
اكثر من 88 شهيدا سقطوا برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلال شهرين ونصف تصعيد ياتي في
ظل مساعي القياده الفلسطينيه الى مطالبه
المجتمع الدولي وفي مقدمته الولايات
المتحده بالضغط على حكومه اليمين
الاسرائيليه خاصه عشيه قمتي شرم الشيخ
الناطق الرسمي باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
اكد ان المجزره الجديده تهدف الى تفجير
الاوضاع وقال ان هذه الاعمال التي وصفها
بالعدوانيه تؤكد ان اسرائيل غير معنيه
بالتهدئه خلافا لكل الجهود الدوليه السعيه
لمنع التصعيد في شهر رمضان
الجهود الدوليه وخاصه الامريكيه تتواصل
فالمبعوث الامريكي الخاص هادي عمرو يواصل
التحضير لقمه شرم الشيخ بهدف وقف التصعيد
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه القمه تعقد برعايه
ام ريكيه مصريه اردنيه رغم عدم التزام
حكومه الاحتلال بالتفاهمات التي ابرمت في
قمه العقبه الشهر الماضي الجزيره رام الله
انضموا الينا من غزه الدكتور صالح النعاني
الخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك
دكتور ما الذي يشجع اسرائيل اليوم على
المضي بهذه السياسه سياسه الاقتحام والقتل
لمناطق الضفه غير ابيهه حتى بردود الافعال
التي يتم التواعد بها
يعني واضح تماما ان البيئه الاقليميه تلعب
دورا رئيسيا في هذا في هذا في تشجيع
الكيان الصهيوني على مواصله هذه الجرائم
علينا ان نتذكر انه منذ التوقيع منذ عقد
قمه العقبه قبل اكثر من اسبوعين اسرائيل
اسرائيل طبعا هذه القمه التي عقدت بهدف
التوافق على اليات لضمان التهدئه في الضفه
الغربيه والقدس المحتله اسرائيل قتلت اكثر
من 30 فلسطيني وجرحت عشرات اخرين
هذه القمه التي عقدت تحت
خفضه التصعيد وتحقيق التهدئه استغلتها
اسرائيل واعلنت بشكل واضح وصريح انها
تواصل
ستواصل هذه الجرائم تواصل اقتحامات تواصل
الاغتيالات دون ان تتخذ الاطراف العربيه
تحديدا والسلطه الفلسطينيه التي شاركت في
هذه القمه اي اجراء مضاد عملي ضد ضد
السلوك الاسرائيلي بالعكس هناك تشجيع على
هذا السلوك من خلال
طيب تحضير الان لقمه شرم الشيخ التي تصب
في نفس الاتجاه اذا البيئه الاقليميه لكن
بالنسبه للبيئه الفلسطينيه هناك نوع هناك
توعد الان من من فصائل فلسطينيه بان ما
حصل في جنين لن يمر من دون رد طبيعه الرد
وكيف يمكن ان يكون عليه الوضع فيما لو حصل
رد واسع
واضح تماما انه الشعب الفلسطيني يا استاذ
حسن منذ مارس
العام الماضي ويعني نسق العمليات الفرديه
وعمليات فرديه وحتى احيانا عمليات تنظيميه
كما حدث مع الرد كما حدث في عمليه الحوار
التي تبين فيما بعد منفذه احد
اعضاء كتاب عز الدين القسام التابعه لحركه
حماس الشعب الفلسطيني واصل هذا النمط
النضالي للمقاوم عن الفصائل انا اسال بناء
على على بيانات الفصائل الان خصوصا وان
الولايات المتحده تتحدث عن امكان اشتعال
الوضع بشكل
واسع وغير متوقع
واضح تماما انه الفصائل الفلسطينيه انكم
تقصد في قطاع غزه يعني سبق انه ردت على
عمليات عمليات الاغتيال والجرائم التي
ارتكب في داخل الضفه الغربيه
عبر اطلاق صواريخ عبر
ايضا عمليات في داخل الضفه الغربيه ذاتها
لكن الموضوع الانسان الحسن يعني يجب ان لا
نعزل الامور عن بعض طالما السلطه
الفلسطينيه تواصل هذا النسق من العلاقه مع
اسرائيل نسق التعاون الامني فانه قدره
الفصائل الفلسطينيه على الرد تحديدا على
ما يحدث في الظفه الغربيه هي يعني قدره
محدوده جدا لانه اهم مركب في الرد على
جرائم الاحتلال هو ايجاد بيئه مشجعه
للحاضنه للمقاومه في الضفه الغربيه للاسف
الشديد السلطه الفلسطينيه بعد قمه العقبه
تواصل الاعتقالات كما حدث في نابلس
وبالتالي بالاضافه ان هناك نقطه ثانيه
يعني مهمه في هذا السياق وهو انه يتوجب
على الفصائل في الضفه الغربيه التوافق على
اليات لمنع عمليات الاقتحام لا يعقل انه
مدينه مثل جنين فيها عشرات الالاف من
الفلسطينيين مدينه مثل نابلس هي مئات
الالاف ان يتم السماح لقوات الاحتلال
باقتحام هناك حاجه لتنظيم عام مقاومه
شعبيه بتشكيل دروع بشريه على مدار الساعه
لمنع قوات الاحتلال من اقتحام المدن
الفلسطينيه هذا الامر لا يعقل وبالتالي
هذا هذا السبع اعاده تقييم من قبل من قبل
الجميع شكرا لك دكتور صالح نعم يا الخبير
في شؤون الاسرائيليه حددتنا من غزه
خلال المتحدث باسم اليونيفال للجزيره ان
القوه الامميه لم تتلقى اي طلب اسرائيلي
للتحقق من حصول تسلل من لبنان الى اسرائيل
وانها لم ترصد عبور اي شخص للخط الازرق
بين لبنان واسرائيل خلال الايام الاخيره
ياتي ذلك بعيده اعلان اسرائيل عن حدث امني
وقع على الحدود مع لبنان مطلع هذا الاسبوع
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قتل شخصا تسلل
من الاراضي اللبنانيه وهو المسؤول عن
تنفيذ تفجير الذي وقع في مفترق مجدو جنوب
حيفا صباح الاثنين الماضي
عمليه كبيره بروايه واحده يواصل المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون الحديث عن عمليه مجده دون ان
يشاركهم طرف اخر الحديث عما وقع وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي
تفقد الحدود مع لبنان وتحدث عن عمليه
كبيره وصعبه ومركبه ومعقده مشيرا في الوقت
نفسه لعدم اكتمال الوصول لتفاصيلها امتدح
جالنت دور الجيش واذرع الامن وتوعد منفذ
العمليه بالندم اريد ان اقول بشكل واضح
انما نفذ العمليه سيندم انه نفذها ضد
اسرائيل ومواطنيها لكنه قتل وفق روايه تل
ابيب ام ان جالنت يحاول توسيع اطار
العمليه الغامضه ليتعدى منفذا قتيلا الى
محرضين محتملين من نقطه مجهوله قالت
الروايه الاسرائيليه المنفرده بالقصه ان
المنفذ عبر الحدود مع لبنان بسياره حملته
سبعين كيلو مترا حتى جنوبي حيفا حيث زرع
عبوه الناسفه عند مفترق مجدو واخذ طريقه
للعوده من حيث اتى الى الحدود اللبنانيه
تتحدث روايه الاسرائيليه ايضا عما قالت
انها عمليات تفتيش واسعه قادت اخيرا الى
سياره المنفذ في بلده عراه حيث ارضي قتيلا
بسبب ارتدائه حزاما ناسفا ما زرعاه المنفذ
القتيل فيما جدو انفجر وادى لاصابه
اسرائيل بجراح لكن كيف يمكن ان يعبر انسان
الحدود اللبنانيه مع اسرائيل التي تعرف
بالخط الازرق والتي ترابط عليها قوات
الامم المتحده يونيفيل تلك القوات نفت
علمها باي حركه عبور للحدود من الجانب
اللبناني الا من تقارير اعلاميه ولاحقا
قال المتحدث باسمها للجزيره انهم لم
يتلقوا طلبا رسميا من اسرائيل للتحقق من
وقوع تسلل حدودي
فلماذا لم تطلب اسرائيل هذا رغم انه يدعم
روايتها لو اكد الرد الاممي حدوث تسلل
الروايه الاسرائيليه المنفرده لعمليه مجدو
تاتي على وقع احتجاجات داخليه وغضب متسع
نطاق يؤرق حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو وتتهم في
سياقه بالتسبب المحتمل في انهيار الدوله
وبينما تسعى تلك الحكومه اقليميا بجهد
حفيث ليس بجديد لحصار ايران تصبح في
مواجهه تقارب وشيك بين الرياض وطهران
الحليف البارز لحزب الله اللبناني الذي لا
تخفي تل ابيب توجيه اصابع الريبه نحوه في
هذه العمليه
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات سقوط وتحطم المسيره الامريكيه
فوق البحر الاسود كشف الفينتاجون بعد
يومين من الحادثه عن صور تظهر مشهد اعتراض
مقاتله الروسيه للمسيره الامريكيه وقد
تحدث مسؤولون امريكيون عن ان القرار
باعتراضها صدر من اعلى المستويات في
الكريندن هذا وقال البيت الابيض نواشنطن
ستواصل استخدام المسيرات في البحر الاسود
لضمان المصالح الامريكيه وتمكين اوكرانيا
من الدفاع عن نفسها ياتي ذلك بعد تحذير
وزير الدفاع الروسي من التحليق الاستفزازي
للمسيرات وتهديده بالرد
احتاج الامر الى يومين حتى تفرج الولايات
المتحده عما تعتبره قرينه تقطع الشك
باليقين ازاء ملابسات الحادث الجوي فوق
البحر الاسود بالنسبه للبنتاجون فان هذا
الفيديو الذي وثقته كاميرا المسيره
الامريكيه يظهر اعتراضا غير امن في المجال
الجوي الدولي ويؤكد بالتالي روايه واشنطن
لا نعلم بعد ما اذا كان الاسقاط متعمدا ام
لا لكننا نعلم ان الاعتراض كان متعمدا كما
ان السلوك العدواني مقصود وكان غير مهني
وغير امن للغايه لدينا دليل مصور على
الاعتراض الذي كان عدوانيا للغايه كما تم
القاء الوقود على المسيره ولست متاكدا من
احتكاك الطائره بها من الواضح اننا لا
نسعى الى صراع مسلح مع روسيا ويجب ان نحقق
في هذا الحادث
التحقيق الذي يبدو مطلوبا من سياق حديث
المسؤول الامريكي الاعلى عسكريا هو تحقيق
مشترك مع موسكو لا سيما انه تطرق الى
مكالمه مرتقبه مع نظيره الروسي
واذ تنصب جهود الامريكيين الان على محاوله
اثبات تطابق الوقائع مع النوايا الروسيه
ضد المسيره العسكريه فقد نقلت محطه ام بي
سي عن مسؤولين في اداره بايدن مطلعين على
تقارير استخباريه قولهم ان اعلى المستويات
في الكرملين اجازتنا وصفته بالتصرف
العدائي ضد المسيره فوق البحر الاسود لكن
لا تاكيد بان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هو من امر بذلك شخصيا
وعلى خط التجاذبات دخل السفير الروسي في
واشنطن محذرا من ان استهداف اي طائره
روسيه في الاجواء الدوليه سيكون بمثابه
اعلان حرب على اكبر قوه نوويه واعتبر ان
اي نزاع مسلح بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
سيختلف جذريا عما سماها الحرب بالوكاله
التي تشن عن بعد على بلاده في اوكرانيا
اما جسم الطائره المسيره الغارق في اعماق
البحر الاسود فلا يبدو ذا اهميه للطرفين
حتى الان على الاقل مع ان اي تحقيق احادي
او مشترك يستوجب ضروره فحسب بقايا المسيره
لاماطه اللثام عن الحيثيات والملابسات
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا قال رئيس
اقليم دوني لروسيا ان الوضع في مدينه
بخموت ما زال صعبا في غضون ذلك افاد مراسل
الجزيره عن تصاعد حده القصف على بلدات
ومدن غرب اخوت شرقيه اوكرانيا واعلنت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه صد اكثر من 70 هجوما
على خطوط التماس في مناطق عده ابرزها
واكدت ان القوات الروسيه لا تتوقف عن
محاوله الهجوم باتجاه مدينه بخموت
ونشرت غرفه العمليات الاوكرانيه مشاهد
لمواجهات مباشره بين القوات الاوكرانيه في
اللواء السابع والستين وقوات تابعه
لميليشيا فاجنر ولم تحدد غرفه العمليات
موقع العمليات مع العلم بان نشاطها
ميليشيا فاجنر يتركز حول مدينه باق موت
التي تحاصرها من جهات عده
وقالت وسائل اعلام نامليشيا فاجنر وصلت
الى بلده خروموفو شمال غرب باخموت الواقعه
على طريق الامداد الاخير للجيش الاوكراني
بالمدينه واضافت المصادر ان معارك عنيفه
تدور في محيط البلده بعد سيطره ميليشيا
فاجنر ناريا على الطريق الذي يمر من داخل
باتجاه مدينه
شاسوفيار المجاوره
على وقع هذه المعارك المستمره تستمر كيا
بمطالبه حلفائها الاوروبيين بتقديم
المساعدات العسكريه خصوصا في ظل النقص
الكبير في الذخائر هذا امر يشهد شدا وجذبا
على صعيد الاوروبي سنناقش هذه القضيه بعد
قليل في فقره في المتابعه
وصف رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه زيارته لليابان
بالخطوه المهمه الى الامام في سياق اقليمي
متوتر عقدت قمه ثنائيه تاريخيه في طوكيو
بين رئيس الوزراء الياباني فوميو كيشيدا
والرئيس الكوري الجنوبي
بغيه احياء علاقات لم تتخلص من الارث
التاريخي المؤلم لعقود الاستعمار الياباني
قبل القمه بساعات قليله اطلقت
صاروخالسيا عابرا للقارات في ثالث تجربه
صاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه منذ الاحد ردا
على المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين سول
وواشنطن
[موسيقى]
مصالحه مؤقته ام دائمه بعد العداء
التاريخي المصلحه تقتضي تقاربا في مواجهه
التهديدات النوويه لكوريا الشماليه لتوسيع
التحالف مع الولايات المتحده منذ 12 عاما
لم تعقد قمه ثنائيه بهذا المستوى بين رئيس
الوزراء الياباني ورئيس كوريا الجنوبيه ما
يجمع فوميو كيشيدا
اكثر مما يفرق بينهما جدول اعمال القمه
وتوقيتها والاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه
والتحالفات القديمه والجديده امور كلها
تستدعي احياء علاقات متوتره من ارث مؤلم
مرتبطا بحقبه الاستعمار الياباني ابرز
ثمار هذه المحادثات التي طال انتظارها
قرروا وزاره التجاره اليابانيه رفع القيود
عن تصدير بعض المواد الكيميائيه للصول بعد
عقوبات فرضت عام 2019 سيعمل
على احياء اتفاقيه الاستخبارات العسكريه
المتوقفه بسبب تدهور العلاقات ما سمع خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك في نهايه القمه
اغلبه ان لم يكن كله رسائل مباشره للجاره
المزعجه كوريا الشماليه
تعزيز العلاقات بين اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه في البيئه الاستراتيجيه الحاليه
امر ملح
التهديد الصاروخي الكوري الشمالي هو تهديد
كبير للسلام والاستقرار ينبغي ان تتعاون
كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان بشكل وثيق
وتتضامن للتعامل بحكمه مع هذه التهديدات
غير القانونيه عن التجربه الصاروخيه التي
سبقت القمه بالساعات وغيرها كان يعلق
الرئيسى قبيل وصله طوكيو اطلقت بيونغيونغ
صاروخان باليسيا ضمن جدول اسبوع مزدحم من
التجارب الصاروخيه واستنادا لهيئه الاركان
الكوريه الجنوبيه الصاروخ بالستي بعيد
المدى وعابر للقارات اما مجلس الوزراء
الياباني فاوضح ان الصاروخ وصل الى ارتفاع
اكثر من سته الاف كيلو متر وهو الاقصى له
تحذيرات والتاثير المزدوج لرسائلها
الصاروخيه هو رد فعل كما تقول على
المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين الولايات
المتحده والجاره الجنوبيه درع الحريه هو
اسم التدريبات التي بدات الثلاثاء وتستمر
عشره ايام تحاكي البيئه الامنيه المتغيره
لكوريا الشماليه بنظر كل منوره عسكريه في
المنطقه هي تدريبات لغزوها ما يزعج بيجين
حاليا اكثر هو توجه اليابان الى العسكره
اعتبر المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
ذلك ادرارا بالسلام والاستقرار
لعبت اليابان دورا فيما تسمى بالتهديدات
الخارجيه خلال السنوات الاخيره وخلق التوت
را في المنطقه ولديها نزعه خطيره للعوده
الى مسار العسكره
التاريخ هو العقبه التي تحل دون تطبيع
دائم بين طوكيو نتيجه التقرب الحالي
رهن تحديات كثيره معقده
[تصفيق]
من مدينه بث في بريطانيا
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه باث
والباحث في معهد
في كوريا الجنوبيه معنا الان سيد مرحبا بك
كيف يمكن ان تقرا هذه القمه الكوريه
الجنوبيه اليابانيه رغم كل ما يسود
العلاقات او ما يسود البلدين من خلافات
تاريخيه
نعم في الحقيقه هذه القمه تعتبر قمه
استثنائيه في الحقيقه هي اول قمه ثنائيه
بين بلدان في اثنتي عشر عاما والسبب
بان مثل هذه القمه كان من الصعب
ترتيبها هو الارث التاريخي بين البلدين
فاليابان والصين تاريخيا
تداولتاس السيطره والاحتلال
لكوريا الجنوبيه وتم ارتكاب فضائح خاصه
اليابان التي ارتكبت في كوريا الجنوبيه
والكوريون الجنوبيون كثيرا ما يشعرون بانه
لم يكن هناك اعتراف كافي من جانب اليابان
بارتكاب هذه الفضاء واظهار شعور بالرحمه
والتعاطف لهم لهذا السبب تعتبر قمه
استثنائيه يعتبر قمه استثنائيه لكن الظروف
التي حتمت انعقاد هذه القمه ما هي هذه
الظروف والى اي مدى يعني تعتبر بدايه
تنقيه العلاقات بين البلدين
انما هو مؤلم في تحسين العلاقه العلاقات
اليابانيه وكوريا الجنوبيه هو حقيقه انها
مردها الخوف والخوف هو الذي
يكمن وراء هذا التقارب بين البلدين من جهه
هناك تلك القضيه الاستراتيجيه التي تتمثل
بالصين والتي في نظري الكثير من البلدان
الغربيه ينظر اليها كقضيه موجبه لكن ربما
سبب الاهم هو اليهو علاقه بكوريا الشماليه
كوريا الشماليه تختبر
منظومات نوويه ومنظومه قنابل نوويه
ومنظومات توصيلها هذا كان طبعا عاملا
استثنائيا وهذا ما يدفع مخاوف كوريا
الجنوبيه
اليابان على وصف الخصوص النكار يختبر
الصواريخ برجع لها تحلق فوق الاراضي
اليابانيه مما اطلق انذارات في منتصف
الليل في هذه البلدان واضح طبعا الناس
سيشعرون بالخوف من مثل هذا المربع وهذا هو
السبب الرئيسي وراء التقارب كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان ربما هناك سبب اخر وهو
سبب داخلي حكومه كوريا
الجنوبيه الحاليه اقرب الى الولايات
المتحده من سابقتها لهذا السبب التعاون مع
حلفاء الولايات المتحده
اصبح يحتل اولويات اعلى بالنسبه للرئيس
ديون في كوريا الجنوبيه
باختصار
المفاعيل الرئيسيه او اذا اذا سالنا عن
ترجمه هذه القمه على الارض يعني كيف يمكن
ان تؤثر فعلا في ردع كوريا الشماليه كما
كما تقول باعتبارها هي الخوف الرئيسي
اليوم للدولتين
اعتقد
كوريا الشماليه
والتصعيد النووي لكوريا الشماليه هو ايضا
سببه الخوف فكتوريا الشماليه
تلقت او تعتبروا انها مهدده بتهديد حقيقي
من التحالف الغربي وخاصه الولايات المتحده
ومن المرجح ان هذا التقارب بين
عدوي كوريا الشماليه ربما قد لا يثني
كوريا الشماليه ربما قد يستفزها اكثر
الامر الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يكون ايجابيا
في هذا القضيه هو ان كوريا الشماليه
تبني قدرات نوويه تكتيكيه وبعض المحللين
يشعرون بان هذا مرده
كوريا الشماليه هذا قدرتها الاستراتيجيه
هي التي
ستجعلة تتخلى عن الدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
وبهذه القوه الرابعه التي كوريا الشماليه
ستستطيع ابتزاز كوريا
من مدينه بث في بريطانيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
من جديد يعود سد النهضه الى واجهه التصعيد
حيث وصفت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه تصريحات
المنسوبه الى وزير الخارجيه المصريه بغير
المسؤوله وقالت انها تحمل تهديدا لاثيوبيا
بشان السد وجددت الدعوه الى حل بشان السد
عبر التفاوض واكدت التزامها بتسويه في
صالح الجميع وكان وزير الخارجيه المصري قد
تحدث عن جمود تشهده المفاوضات مع اثيوبيا
معتبرا مساله السد اولويه وجوديه تمس حياه
الشعب المصري ومضيفا ان كل الخيارات
مفتوحه
معنى من ادريس ابا كيران قديسي الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ومن القاهره عطيه عيسوي
الخبير في شؤون الافريقيه في جريده
الاهرام
نبدا مع تديسي
سيد تديسي الا يحق لمصر
ان تدافع عن وجودها الذي يمثل
نهر النيل ومياه النيل تمثل اصل هذا
الوجود الا يحق لها ان تدافع عن ذلك
هل يمكن نعم تقول تقول اثيوبيا او بالاحرى
اثيوبيا ترفض تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
المصري لكن مصر الا يحق لها ان تدافع عن
وجودها المتمثل بنهر النيل ومياه نهر
النيل وحصتها فيه
اعتقد ان المفارقه تكمل هنا
مثلما مصر مصالحها وهي تعبر عنها المره
الاخرى لاثيوبيا ايضا مصالحها
الطبيعيه والتي ترتبط
بالنهر ولهذا السبب
اثيوبيا اهميه قصوى
للنهر النيل كما تفعلوا مصر تماما لهذا
السبب من منظور الشخصي انا ارى انه مفهوم
لمصر عن
تسعه وراء مصالحها لكن التصريحات
الاستفزازيه لا ينبغي ان تعتبر تعبيرا عن
المصالح
والحقوق لانها سوف تؤدي الى ظروف سيئه
وهذا من مصلحه المنطقه ككل
سيد عيسوي
اديس ابابا تدعو الى الحوار والى حل ازمه
سد النهضه
بالحوار والاتفاق في حين ان مصر
كما يقول ضيفنا من من اديس ابابا تعتمد
اللغه الاستفزازيه لماذا لا يكون اللجوء
الى الحوار بدل توتير
الاوضاع على خلفيه السد
اولا هذا ليس ليس هذه ليست تصريحات
استفزازيه هي تذكير للعالم وللمهتمين
بالامن والسلام في المنطقه بان لمصر حقا
يجب الحفاظ عليه في مياه النيل الذي تعتمد
عليه بنسبه 97% لانها ليست لديها مورد اخر
للمياه العذبه
ثانيا مصر اعلنت مرارا استعدادها للتوصل
الى اتفاق والاستئناف المفاوضات اذا توفرت
الاراده السياسيه من الطرف الاخر وهو
اثيوبيا لحتى الان
المفاوضات تدور في حلقه مفرمه وتصل الى
طريق مسدود في كل مره بسبب رفض اثيوبيا كل
الاقتراحات التي تم تقديمها سواء من مصر
او من السودان او من اداره من الاداره
الامريكيه في عهد الرئيس السابق
وكما تعلم هناك اتفاق او شبه اتفاق تم
بنسبه 90% ولم يتبقى سوى عشره بالمئه
ورفضت اثيوبيا التوقيع المبدئي عليه بينما
وقعت مصر عليه طبعا مصر لا يمكن ان توافق
على شيء سوى التوصل الى اتفاق قانوني ملزم
يلزم كل الاطراف بتنفيذه وليس مجرد
اجراءات ارشاديه كما تريد اثيوبيا لاداره
مياه النهر واداره السد بغير ذلك لا اظن
انه يمكن التوصل الى اتفاق سيد تاتسي
السمعة الى ضيفنا من القاهره والسؤال
المطروح هنا طيب
كيف يمكن لادرس ان تدعو الى حوار
وهي
لا تتوصل او بالاحرى ترفض الاتفاقات وفي
نفس الوقت وصلت الى التعبئه الرابعه يعني
هي تريد ان تستفيد من الوقت ان تضيع الوقت
من اجل ان تعبئ كما تريد السد ثم تدعو الى
الحوار على الملا
نقطه مهمه اود ان
اكررها وهي قوله ان المفاوضات تدور في
حلقه مفرغه هذا صحيح لكن السبب الذي اورده
ليس صحيحا هذه الحلقه المفرغه ترجع في
المسؤوليه فيها على كل الاطراف
والذين يريدون الى المحافظه على الوضع
الراهن وخاصه
المصريين الذين يتمسكون بالوضع الراحه منذ
فتره طويله بالطبع 90% من الاتفاق تم
التوصل اليه لكن العشره في المئه الباقيه
ما تزالت تشكل تحديا لماذا هذه نقطه مهمه
مثلما لمصر بضعف قلقها اثيوبيا لديها ايضا
ضاعت
ومصالحها لكنها مع ذلك تنخرط بشكل فعال من
خلال منصه الاتحاد الافريقي
وتتفاوضوا بحسن النيه في عمليه الحوار
والتصريحات الاخيره
هي حقيقه
العبثيه ولا تضيف اي قيمه لعمليه التوصل
جهود نعم اتضحت الفكره سيد عيسى العشره
بالمئه تتحمل مسؤولياتها المسؤولياتها مصر
وليس اديس ابابا كما يقول ضيفنا الاثيوبي
لا لا لا هذا هذا غير صحيح تماما لان مصر
عرضت
اقتراحات كثيره رفضتها اثيوبيا منها على
سبيل المثال انها تضمن اقتراح يضمن
لاثيوبيا تشغيل سد النهضه لانتاج الكهرباء
بنسبه 80% من طاقته في حاله اسوا حالات
الجفاف ومع ذلك رفضت اثيوبيا المساله
واضحه تماما كيف العلاقات بين الدول كما
تعلم لا تقوم على حسن النيه ولا على
العلاقات الشخصيه تقوم على اتفاقيات يتم
احترامها من قبل كل الاطراف بدون هذا
الاتفاق القانوني الملزم الذي يتضمن اليه
الفصل في الخلاف عند تنفيذه اذا تم التوصل
اليه زائد ضمان
مرور المياه بقدر كافي لا يعرض امن مصر
المائي ولا امن السوداني المائي
للخطر
خلال فتره الجفاف والجفاف الممتد بدون ذلك
لا يمكن ابدا ان يكون هناك يعني اتفاق
عادل ثانيا ان مصر اعترفت بالسد واعترفت
بحقه اثيوبيا في التنميه وفي انتاج
الكهرباء واثيوبيا لا تريد الاعتراف بحق
مصر في المياه اللازمه شكرا
من القاهره الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه في
جريده الاهرام وشكرا لضيفنا من اديس ابابا
كرام تاتسي الباحث والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
الى مشهد الاحتجاجات المتصاعد في فرنسا
بعد اعلان الرئاسات الفرنسيه اقرار الرئيس
منو الماكرون مشروع قانون اصلاح التقاعد
دون تصويت برلمانيه اعتمادا على ماده
دستوريه هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره والتي
نشاهد صورها مباشره على الهواء في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس واضح انها احتجاجات
تشتد
وتييرتها في هذا المساء كما تظهر هذه
الصور وقد دعى الرئيس ماكرون دعا رئيسه
الحكومه الاجتماع قبل بدء جلسه لمجلس
النواب للتصويت على مشروع قانون التقاعد
مساء اليوم وقبل التصويت عبرت مصادر قريبه
من الحكومه عن خشيتها من عدم تامين اغلبيه
داخل مجلس النواد لتمرير مشروع القانون
كان مجلس الشيوخ قد صدق صباح اليوم على نص
مشروع قانون التقاعد باغلبيه
193 عضوا مقابل اعتراض واربعه عشر وقد
تبنى مجلس الشيوخ النسخه نفسها التي
اعتمدت اللجنه البرلمانيه المشتركه
متساويه الاعضاء بين مجلسي الشيوخ والنواب
يوم امس الاربعاء
من باريس زوم ستيك مدير قسمه سياسه
والابحاث في معهد ابسوس مرحبا بك سيد
ستيفن هذه الصور التي نتابعها مباشره
احتجاجات متصاعده مستمره واضح ان
اقرار القانون
بتوقيع الرئيس
لم يهدئوا بالاحرى لم يضع حدا للمشكله
ويبدو ان الشارع اكثر تصاعدا في احتجاجاته
الى اين تسير الامور في في فرنسا
ما حصل اليوم هو ان الحكومه والرئيس قرر
ان يفرع بالقوه قرارهم بالقرار بان لا
يلجا الى تصويت البرلمان وفرض هذا المشروع
القانون هذا طبعا الخطر هنا هو ان غالبيه
النواب بعد سيطالبون
باستقاله رئيسه الوزراء وهذا ممكن وثم
يطرح سؤال كيف يتصرف الفرنسيون وخاصه
المحتجين
وبالتالي اذا كان الرئيس يريد ان يتجاوز
يتجنب التصويت البرلمان ويفرض هذا القانون
وهذا لكن هذا سيزيد من شده قوه المعارضه
الذين لديهم شعبيه كبيره وغالبيه كبيره من
الشعب ضد هذا القانون وبالتالي فان حركه
الاحتجاجات ستشتد بالتاكيد وهذه احتماليه
كبيره جدا في الايام القادمه
والاحتماليه ايضا كما قلت طرح الثقه
بالحكومه واسقاط
واسقاط الحكومه هل يفضل الرئيس مكروه ان
تسقط الحكومه
مقابل ان يضع توقيعه على هذا القانون
ويتجنب الجمعيه الوطنيه
المخاطره كبيره وهذا الواقع الدليل على
ضعفه فهو معزول في حياه السياسيه الفرنسيه
اليوم وقيامه بذلك يدل على لا يتمتع
بغالبيه في الجمعيه الوطنيه
وحتى
اليمين اذا هو قام بحسابات
بانه غالبيه النواب لن يجتمعوا
لاسقاط الحكومه ورئيسه الوزراء بورنو وهذا
احتمال ربما سيتصل في ذلك وعندما نناقشه
مع المحللين هو بامكانه ان يمنع استقاله
ببضعه اصوات من النواب لكن مهما كانت
نتيجه هذا هذا اقتراح لحجب الثقه عن رئيسه
الوزراء والحكومه فلذلك حتى لو كانت ليس
لصالحه هو فهذا على الضعف الرئيسي
وبالتالي يدل على انه لديه خوف فهو طبعا
كان من الافضل ان يسحبها مشروع القانون
هذا
والفرنسيون وبشكل المتزايد يشعرون بعداء
عدم ارتياح للرئيس ماكرون مهما كانت نتيجه
التصويت فان علاقه الرئيس ماكرون مع
المواطنين الفرنسيين ستتفرر وتتاثر وتؤثر
على حياته السياسيه
والسنوات القادمه ثم زالت لديه مده اربع
سنوات الحكم وهذا سيعقد بعمله في السلطه
في باريس مدير قسم السياسه والابحاث في
معهد ابسوس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في دائره الحظر واخر الفصول في بريطانيا
التي حضرت استخدام التطبيق في الاجهزه
الحكوميه هو امر ردت علي الشركه بانه
محكوم بالوضع الجيو السياسي الاوسع كان
صحيفه قد قالت ان الولايات المتحده طالبت
الشركه المالكه لتيك توك ببيع حصص ملاكها
الصينيين تحت طائله حظر التطبيق
اكثر تطبيقات الهواتف الذكيه اثاره للجدل
واكثرها استعمالا واستهلاكا للوقت في
العالم
تيك توك المملوك لشركه باي دانس الصينيه
في بؤره نزاع قانوني وسياسي مع الولايات
المتحده ومعها لفيف من دول غربيه اخرى تم
حظره على الهواتف المملوكه للموظفين
الحكوميين في كل من الولايات المتحده
وكندا وبلجيكا واستراليا والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه واخر الملتحقين بالركب بريطانيا
في الولايات المتحده بدات تهديد بالحظر في
عهد ترامب وتزامن مع ازمه عملاق
التكنولوجيا الصيني هواوي والقوائم
السوداء التي دخلت فيها ايضا شركه صناعه
المسيرات دي جي اي التوجس الغربي من تيك
توك دفع الولايات المتحده الى مطالبه ملاك
التطبيق ببيع اسهمهم في الشركه المالكه
للتاكد من عدم ارتباطهم بالحكومه الصينيه
من جهه اخرى تقول بيجين ان واشنطن لم تقدم
اي دليل يثبت تهديد التطبيق للامن القومي
الامريكي مع مطالبه صينيه بالتوقف عن نشر
ما تقول انه مزاعم خاطئه دواعي الحظر
مخاوف من وصول التطبيق الى المعطيات
الشخصيه للموظفين الحكوميين لهذه الدول
وهيئاتها ومنها الى اسرار الدول والمؤسسات
والشركات فاتفاقيه الاستعمال التي وقع
عليها مستعمل التطبيق قبل تفعيله تتيح
للتطبيق الوصول الى طيف واسع من المعطيات
الخاصه منها الموقع الجغرافي والمعطيات
البيومتريه وحركات المستعمل في التطبيقات
الاخرى ولا يختلف تيك توك في هذا الشان عن
تطبيقات اخرى مثل انستجرام وفيسبوك وتويتر
لكن الفرق انه صيني وهنا مبعثها وجنس
الدول الغربيه في ظل تنام المنافسه بالنظر
لما تقول هذه الدول انه تاريخ طويل للصين
في سرقه الملكيه الفكريه وفي الخلفيه يظهر
سبب اخر وهو الفرق بين التطبيق وشروط
استعماله في الصين وباقي دول العالم هاجس
يتلامى خصوصا في صفوف المحافظين في تلك
الدول الذين يتهمون التطبيق بتخريب عقول
الصغار فالنسخه الصينيه والتي تدعى دون
تضع حدا زمنيا لصغار السن لاستعمال
التطبيق في اربعين دقيقه يوميا من الساعه
السادسه صباحا الى غايه العاشره مساء
ويفرض دون في الصين على منهم دون سن
الرابعه عشره استعمال النظام تصفح امن
يطلق عليه نظام المراهقين تقول تقارير
غربيه انه يعرض محتوى يحث على الجد
والاجتهاد ويعرض نماذج ملهمه اما في باقي
الدول فلا شروط ولا حدود الاستعماله من
طرف الاطفال والمراهقين لا زمنيا ولا في
نوعيه المحتوى المعروض
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الاعزاء مع استمرار الحربي في
اوكرانيا تؤكد الدول الغربيه استمرار
نهجها بالامداد عسكريا كاولويه على جدول
المساعده لكن هذا الملف يشهد جدلا اوروبيا
متجددا ومنفصاع
دا حيث يرى الاوروبيون ان
تحرق قذائف 155 ملم بوتيره اسرع بكثير من
تامينها من قبل حلفائها وداعيمها بحساب
بسيط فان الجيش الاوكراني السالك في معارك
نحو
357 قذيفه شهريا فيما ينتج الاوروبيون
اربعمائه وخمسين الف سنويا لكن لماذا
قذائف 155 مليمتر بالتحديد الجواب لانها
مخصصه للحروب عاليه الشده وان احدا لم
يتخيل ان يندلع هذا النوع من الحروب
لاسيما في اوروبا وهذا الحديث للمفوض
الاوروبي للصناعه اتياري بروتون الذي قال
ان الولايات المتحده في اسوا حاله من
القاره الاوروبيه فيما يتعلق بتصنيع هذه
القذائف وان خطوط الانتاج الاوروبيه
لهذه القذائف اعلى من الامريكيه بالارقام
يتم الحديث اوروبيا عن نيه شراء مليون
قذيفه 155 مليمتر خلال هذا العام بقيمه
اجماليه ستصل الى اربعه مليارات يورو لهذا
تقول المفوضيه الاوروبيه انها ستتحرك
لزياده انتاجها من هذه الذخائر لتشمل خمسه
عشر مصنعا في 11 بلدا اوروبيا كبلغاريا
وسلوفاكيا وهنا نلاحظ ان الحديث عن
الانتاج وليس عن الشراء حيث باتت ترتفع
اصوات داخل الاتحاد تتصدرها فرنسا بان
تامين الذخائر لاوكرانيا ينبغي ان ينتج
اوروبيا لدعم الشركات والمصانع وليس بان
يتم الشراء من الخارج
منذ بدء الحرب الاتحاد الاوروبي قدم عده
حزم مساعده عسكريه لدعم كييف
عدد هذه الحزم بلغ سبعه
سبعه او سبع حزم بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات و600
مليون يورو اخرها في شهر فبراير الماضي
بقيمه 500 مليون يورو اضافه الى حزمه خمسه
واربعين مليون يورو من اجل جهود التدريب
لبعثه الدعم العسكري التابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي في اوكرانيا تركز الدعم الاوروبي
العسكري لاوكرانيا في تقديم صواريخ ستينجر
والمئات من المدرعات والدبابات والذخيره
المدفعيه والالاف من الصواريخ المضاده
للدروع اضافه
للتزويد بالوقود الضروري للمعدات العسكريه
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من هام
فيليب انجرام الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
سيد فيليب وانا اقرا كل هذه الارقام
وازمه التصنيع
لدى الاوروبيين والامريكيين اسال عن
الجانب الاخر المعركه من الجانب الروسي
حتى الان لم تظهر هذه المشكله
اقله الى العلم موضوع نقص الذخائر لماذا
الجانب الروسي لديه فعلا ايضا مشكله في
الذخائر
المخابرات
البريطانيه في خمس مناسبات اشارت موضوع ان
روسيا بدات تنفذ ما لديها من
قذائف
المدفعيه والصواريخ وهذا وبالتالي بداوا
يضطرون الى شراء مزيد من ذلك الشهاب
مسيرات شهاب وايضا استخدامه مجموعه فراك
بالتوجه الى كوريا الشماليه لشراء الذخائر
لو ان روسيا لديها الذخائر التي
تدعيها لما اخترت تذهب الى الدول الاخرى
لتحصل عليها في حين ان اوكرانيا تغير
ذخائرها
كان في البدايه يستخدمون الكثير من
الذخائر لصناعه السوفييتيه وبدت ان تصلهم
الذخائر الاخرى الغربيه وانواع اخرى من
الذخائر ثم هناك
تسجيل جيد من هذه المواد اليها من كل دول
اوروبيه لكن نوعيه هذه الاسلحه وهذه
الزخائر وحزم المساعدات حتى الان يعني لم
تمكن اوكرانيا من استعاده اراضي بل على
العكس يعني يبدو في شرق اوكرانيا الوضع
الميداني يميل لصالح الروس اكثر
هل المشكله في نوعيه الاسلحه المقدمه
[موسيقى]
كلا المشكله ان الوضع معقد للغايه فان
الارضيه غير جيده للمناورات البريه فان
الثالث بدا
يذوب والارض اصبحت كثيره الوحال بعد يصعب
نقل العجلات عليها
انتظر نهايه الربيع وبدايه الصيف يمكننا
ذلك نبدا بالمناوره والحركه والاوكرانيا
الان
قد تحتاج الى المزيد فقد قد تعرض المزيد
من الضربات من روسيا والان ترد اراضيها
بسرعه وطبعا مساحه واسعه جدا في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي لابد القيام بذلك
وجبات معقوله للسيطره عليها بيحدثون
حمايتها وثم التقينا الى مناطق اخرى وهذا
ما يخطط له
الاوكرانيون وايضا خاصه
الدبابات وانواع الاسلحه الاخرى التي تاتي
اليهم التي ليس جاهزه للنشر حاليا في
اوكرانيا لاوكرانيا لا تزال تدرب جنودها
ليس فقط على تشغيل هذه الاسلحه بل طريقه
التزام والتنسيق ما بين الصحه المختلفه
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي منهم شكرا
جزيلا لك
بهذا تنتهي جوله الحصاد الليله شكرا
للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]